Pronto fui parte de un grupo de mujeres con no más de 30 años
cuyos cuerpos se estaban derrumbando.
Lo impactante era cuántos problemas teníamos
para que nos tomen en serio.
Supe de una mujer con escleroderma,
una enfermedad autoinmune del tejido conectivo,
a quien le dijeron durante años que todo estaba en su cabeza.
Desde el comienzo hasta el diagnóstico,
su esófago estaba tan dañado
que nunca más pudo volver a comer.
A otra mujer con cáncer de ovarios
simplemente le diagnosticaron menopausia precoz durante años.
Una amiga de la universidad,
con cáncer cerebral mal diagnosticado como ansiedad durante años.
Esto es por lo que me preocupa:
desde mediados de la década de 1950, la tasa de enfermedades autoinmunes
se han duplicado y triplicado.
El 45 % de los pacientes a los que finalmente se les diagnostica
de una enfermedad autoinmune conocida,
en un principio han sido diagnosticados como hipocondriacos.
Como la vieja histeria, esto tiene que ver con el género
y con las historias que creemos.
El 75 % de los pacientes de enfermedades autoinmunes son mujeres
y en algunas, el porcentaje sube al 90 %.
Aunque estas enfermedades afectan desproporcionalmente a mujeres,
no son enfermedades de la mujer.
La encefalomielitis miálgica afecta a niños y a millones de hombres.
Y, como un paciente me dijo,
tiene sus más y sus menos,
y si ven que eres una mujer te dicen que estás exagerando los síntomas,
pero si eres hombre, te dicen que tienes que ser fuerte, que tienes que aguantarlo.
Y puede que sea incluso más difícil para un hombre ser diagnosticado.
Mi cerebro no es lo que era.
Esta es la parte buena:
A pesar de todo, aún tengo esperanza.
Muchas enfermedades se creían psicológicas
hasta que la ciencia descubrió sus mecanismos biológicos.
Los pacientes de epilepsia podían ser internados a la fuerza
hasta que el electroencefalografía midió actividad eléctrica anormal del cerebro.
La esclerosis múltiple podía ser mal diagnosticada como parálisis histérica
hasta que la tomografía y la resonancia descubrieron las lesiones cerebrales.
Y recientemente pensábamos
que la úlcera de estómago era provocada por el estrés
hasta que descubrimos que la H. pylori era la culpable.
La encefalomielitis miálgica nunca se ha beneficiado de la ciencia
como otras enfermedades,
pero eso está empezando a cambiar.
En Alemania, los científicos han encontrado evidencia de autoinmunidad
y en Japón, de inflamación cerebral.
En EE.UU., científicos de Stanford están descubriendo anormalidades
en el metabolismo energético,
que hay 16 desviaciones estándar lejos de lo normal.
Y en Noruega, investigadores tienen en marcha un estudio médico en fase 3
sobre una droga contra el cáncer que en algunos pacientes causa remisión completa.
Otra cosa que me da esperanza
es la resistencia de los pacientes.
La red nos unió
y compartimos nuestras historias.
Devoramos toda investigación que hubiese.
Experimentamos con nosotros mismos.
Nos convertimos en nuestros propios médicos y pacientes
porque teníamos que serlo.
Y lentamente añadí 5 % por aquí, 5 % por allá,
hasta que, eventualmente, un buen día
pude salir de casa.
Aún así tenía que hacer elecciones ridículas:
Hoy ¿me sentaré en el jardín 15 minutos o me lavaré el pelo?
Pero me dio la esperanza de que podía ser tratada.
Tenía un cuerpo enfermo; eso era todo.
Y con la clase de ayuda correcta, quizás un día yo podría mejorar.
Me junté con pacientes de todo el mundo
y empezamos a luchar.
Llenamos el vacío con algo maravilloso,
pero no es suficiente.
Aún no sé si podré volver a correr de nuevo,
o caminar cualquier distancia,
o hacer alguna de esas cosas cinéticas que solo logro realizar en mis sueños.
Pero me siento muy agradecida de lo lejos que he llegado.
El progreso es lento,
y tiene altibajos
pero mejoro un poquito cada día.
Recuerdo cómo era estar atrapada en ese dormitorio,
cuando habían pasado meses desde que había visto el sol.
Pensaba que moriría ahí.
Pero aquí estoy hoy
con Uds.,
y eso es un milagro.
No sé qué habría pasado de no haber sido una de los afortunados,
si hubiese enfermado antes de Internet,
de no haber encontrado mi comunidad.
Probablemente me hubiese quitado ya mi propia vida,
como muchos otros han hecho.
¿Cuántas vidas pudimos haber salvado hace décadas,
de haber hecho las preguntas adecuadas?
¿Cuántas podríamos salvar hoy
si decidimos empezar de verdad?
Incluso una vez que la verdadera causa de mi enfermedad sea descubierta,
si no cambiamos nuestras instituciones y nuestra cultura,
haremos lo mismo con otra enfermedad.
Vivir con esta enfermedad me ha hecho entender
que la ciencia y la medicina son asuntos profundamente humanos.
Los médicos, científicos y funcionarios públicos
no son inmunes a los mismos prejuicios
que nos afectan a todos.
Tenemos que pensar de manera diferente sobre la salud de las mujeres.
Nuestros sistemas inmunes son tanto un campo de batalla para nuestra igualdad
como lo son el resto de nuestros cuerpos.
Tenemos que escuchar historias de pacientes
y tenemos que estar dispuestos a decir "No sé".
"No sé" es algo bello.
Con "No sé" empieza el descubrimiento.
Y si podemos hacer eso,
si podemos acercarnos a la gran inmensidad de todo lo que no sabemos
entonces, en lugar de temer a la incertidumbre,
quizá podamos saludarla maravillados.
Gracias.